welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast I'm your
host his
and on this week's episode I was joined
by Daniel wilshere
this is a slightly different
conversation but an important one
I met Dan at the beginning of this year
at a networking event and it's the
conversations that we have in this
episode are very focused on Mental
Health suicide and much more
so I wanted to firstly say for those of
you that that may Trigger or be a really
difficult conversation to listen to then
I definitely want to sort of give you
the the heads up on that on this
conversation but what we really tried to
do is ultimately enable all of you to
walk away with practical tips insights
coping mechanisms habits that can help
all of you just manage those really
difficult days that come with uh life
and particularly working in recruitment
down the story is a really difficult one
so enjoy the episode Dan welcome to the
podcast
pleasure to be here mate pleasure to be
here luckily no strange train strikes
today so an easy Journey mate
stress-free no yeah thanks for um making
the trip obviously we met on the off
chance
um I was looking today we met in in
March this year
at the power Hive event
and yeah that's gone quick in that so
yeah like as I was just saying to you
it's it's been really obviously we then
connected on LinkedIn and we had some
good chat on on that um at that event
and it's been yeah really great sort of
following your journey really seeing
that you're doing more and more work
with recruitment companies
um I've seen obviously the the content
that you share and I think when we
prepared for this I think what what's uh
different or unique about you is uh just
how relatable I think you are sometimes
I think when you can go into
um
sort of mental health context with
certain people it can sometimes be hard
to connect uh with with people and I
know that's something that you've had
good feedback on so I'm really sort of
excited to
um go into your journey and why you've
uh ended up going on this Mission uh
that you're on uh so I guess we were
just saying right I think the perfect
place to start is definitely just to
give people listening a bit of color of
of your story
um and I've tried to do as much prep as
possible so why don't I just kick it off
and then you can sort of fill in the
blanks and then what we're going to do
is then we're going to sort of start
talking about yeah through all of that
what you've learned how people listen to
this can hopefully get better at
speaking up about their mental hardship
hopefully equip people listening to this
um so they can spot signs uh that could
potentially become
um big things later on hopefully equip
things that managers can use that they
can support on their team help manage to
be more approachable just we're going to
end up getting hopefully into really
practical useful things that people can
use day to day particularly in a
recruitment context
but this is sort of what I found out
about you Danny basically so
the the the key part that
um whenever you go on your website and
some of the content that I've seen
obviously a huge
um moment and a part of your story was
obviously losing your dad to Suicide but
from what I sort of found out obviously
I guess a lot of people would assume
that the story starts there but from
what from what you shared obviously you
grew up in Rochdale
um and for you you felt like the story
actually started
um when he was more five years old where
you lost two your grandparents your
parents divorced
um and this is before obviously
unfortunately lost your your father
um so I guess why didn't why didn't we
just start there because if if that's
where you feel like the story starts uh
I guess let's let's paint some color
there of of Danny five years old getting
up to nine years old and then we can
then segue into you getting a bit older
and the hardship that you you find
yourself going through amazing amazing
and you have done your research so thank
you appreciate it
I think that that for me and again that
story does as much as the suicide was a
huge Catalyst and was kind of that
pivotal moment of change that really
deterred my world upside down there are
also the reason I talk about some of
those uh some of that loss earlier on is
because of
the way that it kind of made me think
and feel I know from a young age so
losing the two grandparents again
parents divorced at five years old so I
remember my dad sitting down and telling
me like Dunham I wouldn't be living with
you anymore I'm not going to be in the
house and as much as you don't kind of
comprehend what's going on it is a form
of loss and then just in the year after
I lost a third grandparent as well so I
had to think from a really really early
age
about questions about life like where
have they gone
um what is life what is death those kind
of moments spurred uh and and started to
grow my emotional intelligence from a
young age basically and I
well like any family we kind of made
made that stuff work anyway when my dad
had left I was kind of five years old
and my mum was kind of a workaholic so
she was a teacher so she genuinely
like you know like people refer to the
moms of Superwoman my mum was like I
don't know how she she still does it
today she still works 12 30 nowadays
working in education but to to look
after us as a single parent
and because we were staying at my mom's
most of the time
um to
kind of getting us up getting us ready
for school in the morning taking us to
the preschool Club to her working all
day for us picking us up from after
school club and bringing us home sorting
us all out and financially supporting us
she kind of went into after the divorce
chasing her career basically and and
really going into that drive mode and I
think my dad kind of went further into
Chaos's relationship was unstable at the
time and and more of the drinking and
the alcoholism and and those sorts of
things and they went on two very
separate Journeys but obviously you're
not really conscious of this as a
nine-year-old so then at nine years old
when uh well as a youngster sorry and at
nine years old then when he actually
took his life that just came out of
nowhere it was like such a shock and I
just didn't understand what had gone on
I had no idea where he'd gone I couldn't
comprehend it I didn't I just didn't
believe for a lot of the time and that
to process as a nine-year-old was was
huge it was like genuinely
uh there's no burden so some could some
any kids should have to to take really
but in the weeks before so the reason
why it got a bit more complex for me
um in the week before it actually called
to speak to everyone in the family and I
was fuming with him at the time so I
tried to put a healthy boundary in place
and my way of doing that was to not
answer the phone so he spoke to everyone
and when the phone was passed to me I'm
like I'm trying to show you I'm hungry
so I'm going to give it back now there's
a lot of guilt that comes along with any
suicide uh the idea that did I tell them
I loved them enough did I clean the
house enough was I the son that I should
have been all those questions do come to
mind regardless of
um other contexts around around the
event but
me not answering that phone made that 10
times worse mate because I'm just sat
there thinking my God imagine if I'd
have just spoke to him so when a week
later I found out he's no longer here I
had a really complex belief system that
was formed I believe that it was my
fault so I needed to make it up to my
family
um I believe that my emotions were too
heavy for people so again kind of that
was the first time I'd shown underwear
it was a healthy response and ended up
losing someone from that so I'm thinking
there's a nine-year-old okay my emotions
are too too much for people let's
internalize them uh man of the family
now as well I had three sisters so I'm
thinking again I've got to step into my
Dad's shoes so there's like this Melting
Pot of belief systems and external
pressures even even from that age which
then made
talking about emotions very difficult
went through High School kind of chasing
the idea of wealth because that was
where my safety was rooted in basically
so if I had all the money in the world I
wouldn't do what my dad had done and I
could look after my family that was the
the thought process behind it and it
worked in high school
kind of was head boy straight A student
six eight thousand five h2bs on the
outside looked amazing
um but it had been seven years since the
suicide and I said a word so that
emotional weight was building and
building
and I kind of dropped from that head boy
to taking cocaine MDMA kept him in
within six months of leaving school
attendance dropped in college it was
what seemed like a complete U-turn but
something that had actually been
building growing over time yeah
so uh Flash Forward then kind of went
into University thankfully managed to
complete my b-tech dropped out of
University after three years because
I've been struggling with depression
anxiety and suicidalation from from the
age of around 17 to 18. set up a small
contracting company so again after
University I was like still chasing the
idea of money and success believing that
that would fix all my issues set up a
contracting company that went wrong
after like seven months entered into the
world of high-end recruitment
so Global Executive search and kind of
with an amazing love the environment and
again that nurtured that idea for wealth
and success so it started really really
hammering down on on how many hours I
was working on chasing the the financial
side of of the job and that worked for a
period of time but it was a complete
disregard of my well-being so I stopped
doing everything that was supporting me
so writing music going to the gym cut my
family off wasn't seeing my friends that
often and when I did see people it was
when I was being Reckless on a night out
because of the pressure that I was
trying to deal with both from the job
and then also the internal way that I
was still carrying from from the life
events and uh after kind of seven months
my performance just went off the edge of
a cliff and it didn't come back up
I ended up going through a Year's worth
almost a Year's worth of therapy and
medication whilst I was doing
recruitment while she's Democratic yeah
so that consisted of kind of running on
my Friday lunches to the therapy
appointment to relive all the the
difficulties and the trauma and to talk
about these things I was running away
from for so long to then run back to the
office and compose myself so nobody knew
which in itself was a challenge and yeah
it got to the point where I had to leave
the industry because
I was just like I can't physically cope
with the healthy pressures of the role
whilst I have all this stuff and I
needed that time to heal so then left
Recruitment and a year after that
started my journey as the UK's youngest
full-time mental health public speaker
uh it's been a year and six months of
that and it's been over 9 000
professionals and students across the UK
that have now accessed the services from
public speaking to staff training to
workshops to mentorship so it has been
but you're all caught up and now we're
here today yeah there we go so what just
so there's so much there so yeah yeah
with the no thank you so much for
sharing that that's all for people I
know I guess like for you now that
um I don't know you've probably told
that story a lot now right
so yeah yeah so so just so I understand
the timeline so when did the yeah so
when did you leave recruitment so I left
recruitment at 22 years old 22 years old
so when when was that was that before
covered was that during covert
pre-covered yep so high uh it was just
before we went into to actually left
who's in recruitment going on to
um covered left then as you said near
the time and then what so when did you
then start on this Mission obviously
your business damage Goods when did that
all start yeah so I after recruitment I
was in kind of a 9-5 sales role um so it
was for an I.T training company
and again I've just gone into lockdown
and I wasn't eligible for furlough so
they kept me on wow
um so I was new in this company
obviously all offices were shut down no
one was in working from home working
from the offices and my kpis mate were
on call times and emails sent and I have
no clients so I'm in this new sales role
everyone else is unfair law there's me
and a couple of managers in um who are
still working and I'm just calling
around offices mate day to day just to
hit numbers and and try and try and make
something of the role and it was really
challenging and that was like a moment
for me where I was like okay I could
potentially lose this and if I do what
am I going to do and then it kind of
spurred the question of okay well if
that was to happen what would I do for
the rest of my life for I just ask
myself the question like what would I do
for 25 grand for the rest of my life if
that salary didn't change like what
would I do and still wake up every
single day and be over the moon today
and it was like working with the kids
around mental health because there's no
way I could have come out therapy and
have been being in this new mental space
and and not give that back it felt like
an obligation to me to me after the
therapy and after after healing and
seeing the progress from the work that
I've done internally and seeing the
progress from the power of conversation
like all of those things I was like
there's no chance I'm coming from there
and being in this place and and not
sharing what I know and and then I was
like right okay well how can I if I'm
going to be a public speaker and if I'm
going to speak to kids how can I how can
I make that really impactful when it
happens
so I started writing a book and bearing
in mind this was at the early days I was
in that company for a year so this was
really early on and damage because it
wasn't set up to a year afterwards but I
started writing this book and that kind
of level of introspection was was
amazing for me because it helped me
really piece together my story from a
timeline perspective from a uh point of
view of what I'd actually experienced
and my emotions and and the feeling
throughout all of those um pivotal
moments and it helped me really
conceptualize my own journey and then I
kind of stopped writing the book because
I realized writing a book was quite
tough
um I was going to pick it back up at one
point and I started to put a bit more
energy into to just
putting some feelers out there in in the
market of education so I sent a few
emails out to some schools and and got
some really good response back and I
knew there was a market for it because
of what they were telling me and
obviously the state of of mental health
within the education system specifically
so I was like right there's definitely a
demand I have this huge passion I know
I'm I'm great at speaking I've been on
stages before I used to perform when I
was young
um I I know that I love to design and I
love that creative aspect of of any role
and it's something that I often found
was was limited in in some of my
positions so I I loved creativity and I
loved designing things I used to write a
lot of music when I was young so I knew
I'd be great at that side so I was like
public speaking that's like everything
that brings together my strengths
um I have the sale side in there and
I've got that meaning and that purpose
so I was like you know what I'm gonna do
this so then I basically designed uh I
got a company in London to to make 100
luxury envelopes with the damage goes
logo on the front after I'd come up with
a business name so that the logo was in
silver foil and then I got these custom
wax stamps made with the damage God's
logo on and I wrote 100 letters uh all
with kind of my journey very open and
honest like like I've just been on the
podcast and noted all that in there and
then put what I'm trying to achieve in
the learning outcomes that would be for
kids and sent these letters off me to
100 Schools and yeah the response rate
was amazing and from that I then started
my journey into speaking in schools and
launched the business and and it just
kind of went from their mate and I love
that yeah it was really cool 2021 then
I'm assuming around then yeah around
then yeah 2021 yeah yeah I love that so
let I just want to go back for a sec if
that's okay you can't as I said thank
you so much for sharing that and I think
I I get this is just personal curiosity
whenever I hear stories like this
um like I think
there's definitely like one there was a
similar story uh when I was growing up
from school I I would guess people
listening I don't know you'd probably
find it hard unfortunately not to have
at least one of these stories in in your
school do you know what I mean where
yeah someone at school
um had lost one of their their parents
um
I just feel like have you obviously I
know you mentioned about the girl and
I'm not surprised to hear that
especially if
I'm sure there's lots of questions like
what if I could have spoke to him I
didn't know that was going to be the
last time I was going to speak to him
all these types of things but have you
have you like proper have you ever found
yourself just pondering like why why why
he took his own life because that must
be a really I'd I'd yeah I can't even
comprehend
what that would feel like but I would
just I feel like that could potentially
eat me up just like why
100 and the tough thing about that is
the
it's like the pursuit
of the answers to those questions
is so important to you at that time even
though you know you will never get the
answers but the pursuit feels so
necessary so you're like I've got these
questions and I know that I'm never ever
going to get an answer but I'm going to
spend 13 years trying to understand why
and and that was like what it was like
for me and and it was tough because I
had to physically put myself in the
shoes of my dad to try and get the
answers that I knew he couldn't give me
that was tough for me because I'm sat
there thinking okay is it because of
this maybe this went on in his life and
maybe was this was going on in work and
I don't did I miss something and
whatever that that for me was tough that
is a journey that again it's
there are no words for how difficult
that is because like you said it does
eat you up because you're never going to
get those answers and it's about coming
to peace with those and there is there
has been a moment and again through the
therapy where I was I was just at peace
knowing that I didn't I didn't need them
you know I mean I didn't need them I had
the event I knew that things weren't
good I knew that he wasn't doing great
and the event gave me everything that I
needed to know around where he was at
and I didn't need the specifics I knew
that that was enough and and coming to
peace with that was was was tough
um it was tough but it also
like thank God I've been able to do so
because I don't think yeah that can go
on for too long really and then I guess
the other thing I just want to go back
to because I didn't think this might
help people is
again when I was sort of preparing for
this from what I heard and listened and
and watched about your story like you
said to mentioned the word 13 years
there and like from what from what I
gathered it took you a long time to ask
for help
or at least accept help
um or maybe ask for it I think one of
the things that you said was
you were leaving breadcrumbs through
chaos to get people to
um hopefully say Danny you're right you
need any help or whatever right yes so I
think what might be helpful here is
obviously you mentioned where yeah you
you uh everything outside looked great
um and then yeah it quickly spiraled
down then you went into uni and then you
had to deal with
um really um difficult periods of
depression and yeah obviously managing
your own mental health and it's really
challenging so could you paint could you
paint a bit of a picture around that
like what does that actually look like
so I'm sorry to bring you back I guess
you have to do quite a bit of this
listen you don't apologize you're good
so so like so when you when you say that
yeah you're severely depressed
um I think you even said there obviously
there's also potential uh toxic
relationship with drugs
um suicide ideation like what what did
that actually look like what did a day
for Danny look like and that could you
just paint a bit of a picture of what
that actually looked like and maybe what
that felt like yeah so in the worst of
it it was so I had a period of I
remember I'll never forget I had a
period of three months where I was kind
of having nightmares four or five times
a week and that had this knock-on effect
so I'd wake up in the morning and I
would just be absolutely spent just
struggling to get out really really
struggling to get out of bed even though
I knew I had work and I wake up in this
chaos
um my living space was often a mess
because I didn't have the capacity to
even to even clean it mate and I would
wake up in the morning and I knew that I
needed to be this uh individual who
could one wear a mask in work but also
Thrive so that because remember my
belief system was that a big month would
fix everything so I was like I need to
be in a really good headspace for me to
create positive outcomes in this
um success oriented environment I'm
about to go into so I remember just
walking every day every morning saying
um you're a strong uh you're strong
you're successful
um you're strongly capable you will be
successful every footstep it was that
there was that much pressure that and I
was trying to physically get myself out
of this point that I was in that every
every footstep on the way to work you're
strong you're powerful you will be
successful that was the one and I would
get to work and again I'd put kind of
that mask on and it was really I think
that was the biggest thing because I
couldn't be myself and the individual
that I was bringing to work wasn't
actually me and and
that that in itself was such a challenge
and I would go home and I would be
really really spent just spent of energy
and
suicidal ideation in work so I would
often have kind of visions of of things
really tough scenarios going on and
feeling like the world was going to end
and the pressure of a role like
recruitment when you're in that
headspace is just maximized because
things that are normal in the role I say
a candid candidate doesn't turn up for
an interview let's say
um let's say a client postpones hiring
because maybe they're going through an
acquisition or something or these things
that are very very normal in that space
turned into huge problems for me that I
felt were world ending and it was like
everything was just imploding on top of
me and I didn't have the the motivation
or the will to actually make change and
just this very negative and downward
spiral that was in context to work but
then if we look at myself and and more
intrinsically about what I thought about
myself it was
and I think the most difficult thing for
me was the lack of trust in my own
thinking process so I couldn't
physically trust what I thought about
myself about who I was about what I was
thinking and there was this huge gap
between
the person that I thought I wasn't who I
actually was as well there was this
massive
um just this massive space and not being
able to trust my own decisions and
needing reassurance for everything
whether that was decisions in work or or
outside of work
um kind of really lost myself and and it
was just tough it was really challenging
not thank you for sharing that I guess
the the other thing that what what's
because I think the other thing that I
jotted down as well that I was gonna say
do you want to touch on the breadcrumbs
yeah yeah I think yeah just because I
think because where I want to sort of
tie this into is I definitely want to
ask you at the appropriate time like
with with everything that you've learned
on this journey and with hindsight like
yeah how can people get better at
spotting those breadcrumbs right because
yeah obviously you would have felt like
you was leaving breadcrumbs but other
people may not have been aware of that
do you know what I mean
um yeah so yeah let's go into that like
because that's what as I said I jotted
that down where you was feeling like
this you had to put on a certain
um Persona when you're at work but I
don't know how many how many people do
you feel knew that when you went home
that was not who you were and I don't
know you was very far from the person
that they were seeing that many people
actually know that how you actually felt
about yourself and what those beliefs
were it's interesting because when I
there are some people who I've spoke to
who were in that environment that I said
you know I genuinely had no idea I don't
know there are a few that I was like you
know I kind of knew something was was
going on on and and it kind of makes
sense now and and there is and I think
that was with the individuals who were
closer to me uh those who were kind of
Associates or just people because I
would honestly I was the best mate at
hiding this I would come into work
smiling I'd be laughing on the ping pong
tables like just putting so much energy
into trying to to be the opposite of
what I knew I was in order to in order
to hide what I was and it was that idea
of like if I looked amazing on the
outside no one would ever think to
question if I wasn't okay on the inside
so I'm wearing Hugo Boss suits I was
broke at the time like you got my suits
wearing all these nice clothes I'm
talking about who's who's a top biller
this year I said listen give me a year
I'm going to be there I mean I'm talking
like the whole world's in the palm of my
hands when I'd actually I'd actually
lost it all and and it's scary to to
know how good I was at doing that but
that was something that had happened my
whole entire life so I was a master at
it because I'd been doing it for years
with my family with my friends even
previously and we talk about those
breadcrumbs so for me those breadcrumbs
I didn't have the capacity to be able to
speak and to be able to tell someone I'm
struggling when I was younger I couldn't
even
I wasn't even conscious of where things
were emotionally in my mental state
so what I would do would was leave
behavioral breadcrumbs and this happened
through education
so again and it's funny because that
same idea in corporate of the image I
was presenting and trying to be this
High performing individual who did very
well in those for seven months
um
that kind of concept is replicated in
high school so I was this High
performing kid playing instruments
performing on Performing Arts nights
football team rugby team uh here and
there on the rugby team not too often
Athletics team and on the outside on the
surface you'd think this kid is is is
it's just there's nothing wrong and he's
overcome everything
that was a great mask for some of the
emotional complexities that I was
showing through behavioral breadcrumbs
so for example I was writing music at
the time as I just mentioned and all the
songs were they were all in a minor case
or all on all sad songs
um they were all about serious
references to suicide and losing people
and how I felt alone and you pick out
these lyrics from the songs I was
actually writing and if you were just
reading them you'd think I I need to
chat to the kid because it was wrapped
up in this wonderful presentation of a
musical piece that
was was very good and I was I was quite
talented on the guitar and the piano I
had a good voice back in the day
um because it was wrapped up in that no
one thought to ask okay are you okay
there was other times where I changed in
my Social Circle
um so changes in my friend group I had
these emotional breakdowns that were
kind of scattered in certain lessons
across school
um I had kind of
um moments where I would isolate myself
from friends and sit myself in the music
rooms on lunch if anyone knew where to
find me would be in the music room
because from year nine I would just sit
and I'd teach myself piano so there were
these kind of behaviors that I was
leaving they were my way of trying to
get people to notice that I wasn't okay
without me actually having to say it
subconsciously but they're not
intensified so as the emotional weight
of the pain grew and kind of the the
difficulty with the the mental health
challenges grew the behaviors became
more extreme so again with drugs for
example so again I I couldn't speak to
people and I wasn't capable of of even
accepting support and anytime anyone
maybe would ask I would like for example
my mum I was great at flipping the
conversation back on her but then what I
would do throughout my life is create
chaos so that I would have to accept
help from someone so maybe financially I
would ruin myself on a weekend when I
was 18 19 20 so that I'd have to borrow
money off my mum
um maybe there were times where I would
um again get involved in
um scenarios where I would end up having
myself or hurting myself where again I
have to have to ask for help so I would
create these these moments of chaos so
that I would have no other option other
than to gain support so that was my way
of kind of crying out without actually
using vocabulary and that happened again
all the way up to getting therapy hey
everyone a real quick one from me this
podcast would not be possible without
our amazing podcast Partners Vin cherry
and Source breaker because you listen to
this podcast you were able to get your
hands on exclusive savings on both of
these award-winning products if you're a
growing recruitment business you have to
check out vincere who are an all-in-one
operating system for your growing
recruitment business with Source breaker
if you want to make sure that all of
your recruiters have the best tools on
the market to stand out and beat their
competition then you have to check out
Source breaker use the link in the show
notes in the comments below and you'll
be able to get yourself exclusive
savings on these amazing products
okay and then yeah that's that's really
interesting right so yeah creating
moments so I guess you get the attention
or those moments where people actually
help and support you right
so I guess the the other thing that I
wanted to to ask then is
from again from what I I heard it I
heard you sort of talk about that you
did you did try things if it's a
self-help books meditation journaling
um but a lot of these things
um did not actually end up sort of
helping
um I guess over a long period of time
will just help you feel like you were
turning a new Leaf or going in the right
direction so I guess like what
was there a moment where because I
remember you telling a story where you
basically got to a point where you
accepted to help you phoned your mum and
said like I need help and she was there
right away but like what what was there
a moment where you're like no I need to
I need to be willing to look at myself
in the mirror and go I do need help like
where where did that how did that moment
arise how did that happen yeah so when
you talk about self-help the the idea of
well it's in the title isn't it the self
and I tried for for 12 13 years
to fix the self with the self and it
didn't work and I think with the
self-help stuff
it wasn't that I needed the help of
myself I needed the help of someone else
and it even got to a point where that
became really toxic so for example I'm
seeing all these and I'm reading about
all these brilliant strategies from
meditation to the power of journaling to
um kind of pushing your comfort zone and
challenging your mind in your body so
all these sorts of things and I'm like
right okay that must be the key to
success from getting me from where I am
now to being in a position where I'm
thriving and I'm feeling good and and
all that sort of thing so
I'm I'm like Daniel okay let's let's get
yourself help structure your self-help
routine and every week what does that
look like meditation every day let's
make sure you're journaling are you
drinking enough water
um let's sign up for a half marathon
because you need something to be able to
work towards physically all this sort of
thing and add all these
um what seemed like really positive uh
elements of of my routine
and and don't get me wrong those things
are great they're extremely important
but it came to a point for me where if I
didn't do a 10 minute meditation I'm not
done you failed again that may
reinforces the idea that I couldn't
achieve and and that I wasn't capable
and and that I wasn't in a position to
to create positive outcomes and really
impacting my confidence and that half
marathon that I signed up for never
actually did
um the journaling just became to a point
and again it became so toxic because I
was had so much they became things of
pressure it was like if I don't do this
then then again it's
um yeah I've failed with it so
I think with the self-help stuff no it's
all about balance do I journal every
single day no do I Journal when I need
to no yes 100
will I meditate every single day no will
I meditate twice a week if especially if
things aren't going too great 100 will I
hope that if I feel like I need to yes
and it's having that self-awareness to
understand when to implement self-help
and and what is right
um and when he's right to do that
so in and in terms of that point you
mentioned of okay so when did things
really change
it had gotten to a stage where
I genuinely there was no there was I
tried so much again from from the
self-help stuff to trying to up my hours
in work to
um trying to to just be someone who
could could fix all this myself
um all the all the journey previously of
those 13 years was was all taking that
responsibility of of healing myself of
looking after my family of of that whole
journey
and then it came to a point where it's
like I've I've tried everything I was
like I I'm spent I am so tired I said
I've been trying this for so long and
it's obvious that nothing was working
and
I knew that if I didn't accept the help
of someone else then the Prosper would
have just ended up pretty much like my
daddy was going it's going up that was a
really scary moment for me because
having been his son I'll be in the son
of someone who's taking the life at nine
years old again I believed that I was
capable of doing that because he's my
dad and surely if my life looks the same
as his I'm going to be capable of doing
the same and I always say because he was
getting kicked out of his home he had
kind of relationship issues problem with
drugs and alcohol mental health issues
financial troubles and I was like at
nine years old if I if my life looks
like that I'm going to do the same and
then here I was after running away for
10 11 years trying to run away from that
image with then struggling financially
with uh not being able to pay rent at
the time with my relationships breaking
down with drugs and alcohol problem with
cocaine having a abused and used drugs
for some four or five years up until
that point
um to the financial all of it I was like
I've spent 11 years running away from
this thing and I've just ended up full
circle back there and that moment for me
was like I can't continue doing this so
I yeah I spoke to my mom
said two words on the phone I'm
struggling
and she drove up we had another
conversation the next day and she just
gave me everything that I needed she she
uh what did that feel like
honestly to finally say I'm struggling
such a relief such a relief and I
remember that at the point where she she
called me in the week afterwards a
couple days afterwards and she was like
um it's like Dan I've organized for you
to go and see a therapist she was like
all you have to do is turn up do you
like it's booked in everything is done
for you all you have to do is turn up
it's in two weeks will you go and I
remember just breaking down and I was
just like thank you thank you I'm sorry
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I kept on
saying over and over again because she
had taken a step that I was never ever
capable or willing to take for myself
but that I need knew I needed so much
and for me that that was it showed me
the power of accepting support and
listen that was the moment where I was
like you know what we we can't always do
things on our own and we need other
people and that intervention from my mum
the action she took was what really
transformed my life because therapy
again was transformational for me and
then so basically you went on that so
what you um do you still have therapy
now or
nope so I did 11 months of therapy
psychodynamic Psychotherapy which looks
at
um unearthing emotions and and kind of
feelings that are trapped within the
subconscious so it's often
um looks at childhood events or this was
the type of therapy that was really
right for me
um so it looks at those childhood events
and belief systems and also how to
navigate relationships as well in in the
present
um so I had a lot of difficulties with
certain boundaries and my relationship
with with others um friends family and
uh relationships with partners all
became very difficult to navigate and
still at times a tough today I still
have to manage that side of things so I
had the psychodynamic Psychotherapy for
uh 11 months yeah alongside taking
medication as well and then that that
was basically that 11 months was you
going on obviously it's an ongoing
Journey right it's not it's never you
don't complete it that's the the joy and
also the crazy part about life right but
you would say that would be that was
like you're healing Journey where you
was having to get into that environment
and you had to answer the questions that
you'd been avoiding up until that point
right I had to speak about things I
thought I would genuinely I'm not
playing this playing the support
exaggerating this I spoke about things
that I believed I would go my whole life
without telling anyone yeah mad and it
was funny like the process
I hated it mate and when I first started
going I hated it I used to walk now I
was angry genuinely angry and I used to
sit in this room and I didn't even in
that room I always tell people in my
talks like for four months we I said we
don't make we didn't make any progress
but I didn't speak about anything
deep or subsurface level for about four
months he would always ask me how's your
week going here doing this in work and
this is it would always be very cerebral
very surface level because I'm still I'm
still putting my toe in the water with
the idea of talking about things that
deep and and that are tough and emotions
and feelings and times I cried and all
this sort of stuff that still is a big
no for me so for the first four months
and I'm broke at the time I'm paying 100
pounds a week for this this therapy and
um for the first four months I'm just
yeah I'm just not talking about anything
serious wasting time and
um
it was funny because he used to ask me
about kind of these sensitive areas
obviously and he'd look for the way my
body would respond so what's your
relationship without your family uh with
your dad so on and so forth
um and he would watch for how my body
would respond because I need to know
which areas he needs to dive into a bit
more
but I would just kind of cut him off I'd
avoid eye contact and look out this
window my whole body language would turn
I wouldn't face him I wouldn't respond
to him and and it was funny that I would
watch the kind of the clock on the
windowsill out this big window in front
of me just go down for for kind of 10-15
minutes at the end of every session
because even in that room like I'm
trying to find a way to escape yeah I'm
trying to find ways to hide even at the
point of knowing that I'm I'm wanting
and ready to heal and it took four
months and I say I started that
a section saying I wasted the time but
it wasn't a waste because I needed that
four months of being in that room of
dipping my toe in the water with some of
that conversation of being asked those
questions I needed that process of of
that four months of tension to then be
ready in order to talk about the
difficult stuff and
then when that happened
I physically I remember there was there
was points where again I spoke about
things I thought I got my whole life
without saying and I remember there was
this one time I got home and I just I
cried me for like 30 minutes
uncontrollable like baby crying before
for like 30 minutes straight I just
couldn't stop after I put this this
specific thing down and it was like that
13 years of pain just left my body wow
and after it I was like I took a deep
breath I was like listen that one that
one needed to come out that one's been
in there for a while and I started to
understand then straight away like right
this is this is powerful this is working
let's do more of this let's talk and I
just started turning up I was like a
different man and and my therapist kept
on saying like how from that point how
well I was implementing everything he
was he was telling me
um how kind of engaged I was with
wanting to to do the difficult work
um and how how more self-aware was
around all the complexities around the
whole journey and I just started to make
this incredible progress and I could see
the results
picking up all this momentum I stopped
having the nightmares started to feel
better about myself I had a bit of chat
back in work because one of the other
things that happened was I was unable to
engage in any of the Social Circles that
that happened in work especially kind of
on end of periods for example or if we
go for meals and drinks I remember just
being sat there in my eyes would be
fuzzy so my eyes wouldn't Focus
couldn't physically speak to anyone I
would just sit in this world of chaos
and that was also tough for me because
the social aspects of recruitment was
really important so to get my chat back
and my laugh and my band-to-back I was
like yes Dan Dan's coming back so I just
kept on working and working through it
and and found more of myself again and
started to implement things through the
therapy
um through changing my belief system
through rewiring some of that stuff that
then allowed me to to feel more content
and to make progress it was
transformational no no it sounds it
um so what let's start going into like
what what we've what we've now what
you've learned from this person because
you've clearly learned a lot and will
continue to learn a lot about yourself
and about others but like for someone
listening to this that maybe still
hasn't been willing to take that first
step
like I don't know I feel like that is
often the the biggest challenge right
taking that first step like like you
said it it took a lot and a lot of time
for you to pick up the phone and say to
your mum that you're struggling so and
I'm sure you get asked this a lot like
if anyone's listening to this right now
and they do feel
yeah they're in that they're in that
chaos and they're they're reluctant
because their own selves are protecting
them there was everything you just said
that you're you're doing everything you
can to protect yourself right in in
those first four months from dealing
with the things head on
that you probably know that you need to
deal with but you know protect it at all
costs like I said you're talking about
things that you thought you'd never have
to tell anyone right so what what what's
your advice for people to like why why
should they take that first up or how
can they how can people
um yeah uh have the ability to take that
first step which often can hopefully
then lead to the things that you're
describing that momentum and getting to
the point
um uh where you are now but how can
people turn that first up
yeah I want to start by saying
me talking about the power of
conversation and how important that was
in my journey and all that sort of
things by no means am I belittling how
difficult a task that is let's just
again that took me 12 13 years I I
didn't the first time I spoke to my mum
about how I actually fully fell
throughout my dad's suicide was 13 years
after it happened exactly that's so much
[ __ ] time it's a long long way over a
decade exactly crazy it's a long while
so I I'm not belittling how tough that
is I'm 100 and it and it is a challenge
and we all have our own pressures that
make that either easier or more
difficult as well
um but I think it's about okay well
first of all understanding you don't
have to offload every single detail of
the blueprint of your psychological
makeup or even begin to
um to talk in in in a massive amount of
depth about the things that you know you
might need to face
all the things that are troubling you or
your mental health difficulties
how can you make that conversation as
easy and as feasible as possible for you
now there's a number of ways that you
can look to do that I think the first is
understanding okay what what are you
comfortable saying
test the waters what are you comfortable
with can you instead of speaking before
speaking about something can you write a
journal about some of these things and
and can you write a a page of some of
the things that you've never spoken
about and how do you feel in that
process is it too raw if it is okay
maybe leave it for a couple months and
come back to it maybe when you're
different in a different space but
writing on a page is a great way for you
to um to to make sense of what can seem
so cloudy and and
um
um so difficult to to comprehend and and
difficult to to actually conceptualize
as well so that's a great way to do it
but it's also understanding that okay
maybe the first time that I'm speaking I
don't have to sit here and talk like
Daniel's just done for the first 20
minutes half an hour of that podcast
about every intricacy in detail can I
just say two words I'm struggling that
was me on the phone I'm struggling that
was enough that was like the most that I
could handle
right in that moment it was like this is
a lot two words is all I've got the next
day I said a full sentence my mum drove
up I said that I've been struggling with
depression anxiety suicidal ideation
I've got a bit of a problem with drugs
instead of full sentence
then I went to my therapist appointment
um and the psycho psychiatric
appointment
um so the consultation before he
directed me to the psychotherapist
and he would ask me questions and again
I would talk to him a little bit more
about my history and then six months
later of working that muscle of
conversation
I was able to sit down and offload more
of the heavy stuff so it's about
understanding it's a process
making that easy for yourself
um I think is really really important
and making that conversation easy for
yourself at the start and then it's also
like okay what other ways or other
things can I do to make that
conversation easy who is it I'm speaking
with so who do I choose to actually to
actually speak with is there someone who
has been vulnerable to me about things
who I know I can trust because they've
shown me that they're they're um they're
not afraid of judgment or that they
trust me is there someone in my
Friendship Circle or work Circle who has
brought something to me and has trusted
and confided in me with something that
could have been potentially
um difficult for them to do so wonderful
is there a person like that I can can
make out and
um and if so where can that conversation
take place where do you think I'd feel
more comfortable we know from research
that men especially feel more
comfortable talking about mental health
and difficulties that they're having in
life when they're doing an activity so
do I feel better when I'm driving doing
that is it better when I'm doing a walk
can it be at the football the football
match
um so it's about making and finding ways
to make that initial conversation easier
and understanding how you feel in that
process so again if it is too much maybe
just leave it for a little bit but if
you if you go there and you like to know
what
feel a little bit better and as much as
that was really hard I feel a little bit
of positivity that's come from me I feel
a little bit lighter my head's buzzing a
bit I feel a bit like I'm on my Center
Line when I'm talking
um that was something I needed to talk
about cool let's put a tiny bit more
into it and it's working that muscle of
conversation
um
also kind of listening to stories I
think that's the biggest thing because
and it's why I do the work that I do
first and foremost and why I give that
raw honest approach and why I talked
about things on a podcast that most
people couldn't even comprehend talking
about in a conversation the reason for
that is because this stuff is normal
I I genuinely don't know anyone who is
who has never ever gone through
something that is is very challenging in
life whether it's losing family
bereavement Financial issues losing a
business there we go through these
things that's life like life is life is
struggle in a sense it genuinely is to
to think that these areas aren't normal
and and to think that we need to hide
these areas because
of of the way Society is and that
they're embarrassing and they're not a
normal part of life and that again we
should shy away from them I think is is
part of the problem because again they
are so normal so if you can listen to
someone in conversation whether it's on
a podcast or maybe someone who has gone
through similar life experiences than
you um to you sorry
that's a great way to normalize what
feels like a unique pressure in your
head because that's the other thing of
the mental health challenges when you're
in it you feel like it's just you you
feel like nobody understands how you
feel and I'm turning up to work every
day and I'm thinking you guys I don't
even know the half of it and yeah you're
telling me why I'm not building off this
much and how much this as much this
month and I'm sat here dealing with 13
years of unresolved childhood all this
stuff I'm like thinking that it's just
me when we know statistically it's not
so I think listening to conversation can
really help normalize what feels
abnormal what feels alien like what
feels like it's just something you're
dealing with and that's a great relief
because then you're like right okay
it's not just me this stuff happens what
has this person done can I try something
that they've done can I learn from them
and and it's that sense it's taking kind
of the fear out of of it and I think
those are some good points to no yeah I
really like the piece about
and yeah you're obviously Testament I
guess I do really like the piece of like
yeah you're not gonna
go from not talking about things to
talking about everything in one therapy
session or just to to someone right like
chip away I start with things that maybe
you're comfortable with like you said
test the waters and then build from
there do it in an environment over
people yeah I really like that so I
guess yeah conversation the the thing
the things I wanted to
um go into then at the latter end of
this conversation is
because I have mine
um views on this so like how from your
journey how important would you say is
self-awareness
huge
uh without without self-awareness
I would not be able to give myself the
things that I need in the times I need
them I wouldn't be able to know um when
I'm thriving how I'm thriving what's
making me Thrive or what's helping me
Thrive what I need to do more of I
wouldn't have any understanding or
roadmap to the areas of myself that I
need to develop in the areas of myself
that I'm actually content with as well
because
I think that's another thing it's like
on the idea of self-help and and
kind of
personal development
is the idea that we feel like that every
single part of ourselves is is not okay
and that it all needs work and that it
all needs to to
um
to be developed and to have that TLC to
it when there's probably a lot of parts
of yourself
that you can look at if you really spend
the time using that self-awareness and
that self-reflection where you can sit
there and go go like you know what you
say I'm like I'm actually really pleased
with this these parts of myself I don't
I don't need to listen to anyone who's
telling me I need to improve these or I
don't need to listen to the podcast
that's on my finances or whatever or
this and this because I'm actually great
in those areas let me focus on the parts
of myself that I need to improve that's
one thing that I've found really
important as well is is understanding
the areas of myself that I do need to
work on and the areas of myself that I'm
actually content with because we can be
left in this void that makes us feel
especially with social media like we
need to to work on every part of
ourselves at every single point in our
lives every single day and it's just not
the case so that self-awareness helps
take some of that pressure off as well I
think it's yeah it's key so how like
yeah I think it's so important and I'm
not surprised that you said that so like
how from your perspective and your
journey like how can people listening to
this
become more self-aware or like yeah
because I I think some people actually
would find that really difficult so how
can how can from your perspective what's
the typical advice that you give for
people to cultivate more self-awareness
yeah well there is obviously the route
of therapy
that for for someone if you want to
learn about
your behaviors and your beliefs and
where they come from and and why they
exist and why you do the things that you
do and all of that again the blueprint
of your psychological makeup therapy is
amazing and you don't have to be in a
bad place to to go to therapy if you
genuinely just want to learn about
yourself and you'll hear all the
athletes and top sports people talk
about it because what you gain from it
is is
is one of the greatest Investments is
that I wouldn't be doing this stuff if I
didn't go through therapy because of the
self-awareness it gave me it helped me
understand
uh the events had gone through beliefs
that had stemmed from those events
behaviors that stem from those beliefs
and how they're impacting my life and
then what you're able to do is be like
okay
um when a something challenges me that
would typically make me fall back into
those urges of taking drugs or being
Reckless or ruining my bank account I'm
able to sit there and go down
yes this thing has happened and yes it's
unfair and yes you want to go and take a
load of drugs at the weekend now however
you know why that exists and you know
where it comes from and you also know
what it brings you so let's go in a
different direction
and when you can do that you start to
really reframe again your outcomes and
change your outcomes and and so therapy
is amazing for that self-awareness and
giving yourself that understanding of
you but also tools like like journaling
people don't understand how powerful a
tool that is because when do we ever
like we'll sit there and we'll learn
about processes in recruitment we'll
we'll learn about sales training and all
this sort of stuff like and we'll write
all these notes and we'll spend hours
and hours and hours bettering ourselves
in that area but when do we actually sit
and then try and spend the time to
understand ourselves and write about how
we feel today and why that could be and
why you had an argument with that person
that was close to you when they
um broke your trust or whatever and why
you've had a certain reaction to certain
things like jotting those things down in
journals is an amazing way because then
what I always notice with my journaling
is I can look back after three months of
journals and I'm like right Dan I've
seen this certain thoughts been coming
up quite often we know we need to put
some time over there you're still having
trust issues in your relationship or
whatever
um yeah we know that's the point that
you probably need to to put some energy
towards so it helps you
um really kind of
encapsulate where you're at where your
thoughts are what you're thinking
um where your behaviors are and then you
can make change from them so that's a
great way to build it and the more you
notice those things the more you can do
it in real time as well not just on when
you're journaling but throughout the day
meditation again people say and they'll
say all the time on meditation for
mindfulness and but it genuinely is like
having that time and that space to to
sit with yourself
with no phone for half an hour with just
you no music on in the background no
nothing there no laptop open
um no work emails coming through no TV
no Netflix on to have that solitary time
which in today's world we rarely rarely
get to have that time to sit with
yourself and to pay attention of okay
where's tension in my body
where do I feel tension have I got any
anxiety okay when I feel anxiety where
does that tend to be is it my stomach is
in my chest does that usually get tight
um and and okay well ask yourself those
important questions of what's serving me
right now
what behaviors am I engaging in that
damage in the relationship that I have
with myself what's improving the
relationship I have with myself like the
quality of the questions you ask
yourself
improves the quality of your life it's
one of those things isn't it the the
more difficult questions and the more uh
complex questions you can ask yourself
about you
the greater answers you're going to get
that are going to help you to improve
your life so the meditation the
journaling if you're looking to do that
personally is great therapy I would
always just recommend for anyone who's
trying to increase that self-awareness
because of of the value you get from it
yeah and I love that some so we did a um
something I really like as well we did a
session a live session uh yesterday with
Katie maycock and we're talking about
self-awareness and there's a really
practical exercise you've probably come
across this or maybe even given this
advice for people but something that she
got
um the group of recruiters to do is just
to ask yourself how are you feeling
um one out of ten ten being great one
being really bad and writing down a
number and if that number is eight or
below you then ask yourself the question
what can I do today to help me get
feeling more towards a tan so even just
simple things like that like how just
asking yourself to question how are you
feeling today and writing yourself out
of 10 is a great way to cultivate that I
think the other thing in line with what
you said as well and I don't do this
every single day but I'd say more often
than not purposely and intentionally I
will not go on my phone for the first
like 30 minutes
um sometimes longer
uh of the day just because like you said
it if if we're all honest with each
other then we can go a whole day
um not having any space to process our
own thoughts and how we're feeling like
we're just always getting external
stimulus
um so I think that's another thing that
people can easily Implement is first 30
minutes don't go on your phone and and
what that means is you are you're going
to be of your your thoughts no podcasts
no music just you're you're yeah you're
just thinking you're processing [ __ ] and
that is hard for people yeah that's hard
yeah so start with five minutes ten
minutes exactly
um so I think that they're they're
definitely there are things that helps
me the other thing I just wanted to ask
you and then let's go on to
um more what you've seen in the
recruitment world and we'll finish there
but how the other part that I think is
really important we spoke about
self-awareness but what about
um personal responsibility
it's huge how do you feel about that
it's huge I think it's key because and I
think
I'll be honest like there's a lot of
expectations on organizations to provide
the solution to every part of our lives
at the moment from kind of healthcare to
um Simon sinek was talking about it to
kind of mental health and all this sort
of stuff to be the solution and
yes to an extent it's really important
those systems and those processes are in
place one thousand percent but there
also comes with a responsibility to want
to access them and and to create change
for for yourself as well and and and
that kind of personal accountability and
personal responsibility in context to
mental health is is key we think about
it with kind of drugs and whatnot if you
know your mental health has been
suffering for a long long while and you
are not doing anything and you're
engaging in drugs let's say at the
weekend and you know that every time you
take cocaine your serotonin levels drop
for 10 days it takes 10 days to come
back up that's not helping what can you
do can you have conversations to make
sure that okay if that's where you're at
how can how can I change that sort of
thing
um so taking that accountability and
responsibility that is the only way that
you you ever
you have you can ever make change I
think it's it's pivotal it is pivotal
yeah because I think that's I don't know
that's just definitely things that yeah
I think again it's difficult for people
to take that I feel like for some people
and I think as long as you
as long as you give power to the things
that you can't control I think you're
always going to struggle do you know
what I mean I feel like this because of
that or I'm this way because of that and
again I think that that personal
responsibility piece is something that
yeah people that's a whole journey I
think as well people have to go on but
like you said if you do take that then
you can grow and you can change yeah and
I know yeah I think that's that's the
other thing that I think that's really
important this is like if you're being
honest with yourself how much power are
you giving to things that you can't
control as to like why you feel certain
things and I know there's so many
there's a lot of nuance and context for
everyone's a different situation but I
think if you try and take as much
personal responsibility as possible
you've got a greater chance of having
more good days than bad days yeah 100
and there are always there are always
things we can control as well I think
that's the beautiful thing in any
situation that are always controllables
and often when things feel out of
control again writing a list of
um just shutting down okay what's
worrying me at the moment or was what's
what's impacting my life negatively at
the moment and writing down that list of
everything that it is and then going
through that list and the ones that you
can't control cross off the ones that
you can control amazing work through
prioritize work through but then there's
also kind of
um that flip side of you you mentioned
about beliefs of not believing we can
change things start with the language
that you use so if I might think like
okay you know what I I don't believe
that I can
like I I just can't stop taking drugs at
the weekend I say that yeah I just can't
I just every time I just can't do it
changing language you say look like yet
add the word yet it's a really really
powerful word but actually creating that
change in your mind of even just the
language that you're using and saying do
you know what I can't stop taking drugs
yet or I can't stop doing this yet
straight away you're telling yourself or
now words the words that we use are
extremely important because they're
powerful they genuinely are and and they
have a big impact on ourselves that
little small change of just using that
word then helps you understand for you
that you know what this is something
that right now maybe not but there's the
possibility in the future and that even
little small changes like that with the
language can be important to change
those beliefs that feel like they'll
never shift
so let let's sort of finish this up on
just one or two things surrounding
recruitment because I think a lot of the
stuff that we've
spoken about today hopefully can
encourage people to to speak up you've
mentioned a bunch of things that have
helped you on your journey that
hopefully will help others
but I guess obviously you worked in
recruitment now obviously I can see that
you're going into a bunch of different
recruitment companies I guess the first
thing I just wanted to ask you to get
your take on again maybe now because
you're out of it and you've been on your
own Journey but why why do you think so
many people within recruitment end up
finding themselves really struggling
with their mental health like what's
your take on that and I think I've got a
bit of a snippet of that yesterday we
had yeah just over 50 recruiter joiners
for the live session and when we did
that exercise I think a third a third of
of
um the people that joined us put down
one
I mean so I think a lot of people yeah
like a lot I was quite surprised to be
fair there was no there was everyone was
under eight everyone was under eight
right so I don't know what what's your
take you're out of it you've been on
your journey you're now going into
businesses like what what's your take on
like why you think um a lot of people
can find themselves struggling with
mental health specifically in a
recruitment context yeah I think well
statistically it's 82 percent of of
recruiters suffer with chronic stress so
it probably correlates with the reason
why majority of them yesterday were
under under eight and some of them even
at one which that's it it's a shame
isn't it is really really tough and I
think it is the the demands of the job
isn't it and and I think those pressures
of the rule there's so many positives
and when I look back at my my journey
and my time I'm like there was so many
like gems that I was learning there was
so much positivity
um the the capability for career
development the financial side of it of
course
um the skills that I was learning to to
deal with people and to manage people
and to understand processes of
businesses like those things are
genuinely invaluable and I wouldn't be
able to to be the person I am today
without what I learned in the industry
there's so many positives but I think
what can be tough is when you have
external pressures because the demands
of the job are quite High obviously
those demands really increase and become
more difficult when we have pressures
outside of work so when we have
additional life challenges that can just
make and Propel the the difficulties of
Recruitment and the stress in
recruitment though like I said those
small things that are normal in the role
become more annoying more frustrating
more stressful you get anger angrier
quicker and and that's why I think
kind of understanding balance and and
the pressures of the role is really
really important and knowing when to
actually take your foot off the gas and
I think it is so easy as well to to
throw yourself into
the role too much where Drive can become
negative where you can
avoid everything that you know you need
to deal with in the pursuit of financial
gain and career development and all
those sorts of things and that's a quick
route to burnout isn't it and I think
that's another thing is is because of of
kind of because of the rule
and because of how easy it is to fall
into to just being consumed by the
position that often we don't pay
attention to the parts of ourselves that
we need to tend to and give some TLC to
so I think
I think again around the stress I think
it is with the obviously the pressures
of the role the the hours again are
difficult but
I think it's
people
um not tend into themselves and give
them to themselves what they need they
have a lot of conversations with a crew
who know probably how they need to
support themselves and it's that
question if I ask you five things to
better look after your mental health
you'll be able to give me them in in
probably three minutes A lot of people
would be able to
a lot of the recruiters they know what
they do need to do to improve their
mental health but it's actually actually
the action of of doing it so it's the
why reason and and and doing the Small
Things
um because a lot of those things as well
what we talk about that support our
mental health they seem so small and
they seem so insignificant that they're
so easy to miss especially when you have
the pressures of the work and the
interviews and the numbers and the kpis
like the small things that actually give
us the support that we need is so easy
to miss
um in the role so I think it's a
combination of that sort of stuff yeah
and then let's end on like for people
listen to this who manage people maybe
um maybe do have a bit of a sense of
they might have someone like Dan on
their team who they can maybe just see a
bit under under the hood but then not
maybe not sure how to approach it what's
your advice for people if you think what
would have
I don't know if it
um this would have happened but like
thinking of you in that work environment
what could have a manager done to make
themselves more approachable uh for you
to at least test the waters or dip your
toe in to go this is how like yeah now
I'm getting I know I I sort of come
across like this but this is how I'm
feeling at the moment like how people
how can people listening to this become
more approachable for people to speak up
and say this is what I'm really
struggling with at the moment I don't
know what advice do you have people on
on that you mentioned it's about
approachability and there's a number of
ways that you can make yourself more
approachable and I think that are really
important for for uh for arming yourself
as a manager to be able to have those
conversations and to not only be able to
to have them but to deal with them
properly and to to be someone who people
can come to with that sort of stuff if
we look at kind of using vulnerability
which was again today we spoke about
vulnerability and how it is genuinely a
superpower I think one of the things is
if
if if you're a manager for example and
you never talk about mental health or
you never talk or or even have the
conversation or if you add to stigma
through the language that you use for
example
um that creates barriers
um and people you can't expect people to
approach you with something that is
again very scary very vulnerable if you
have have been out into stigma if you
use
um words like crazy or if you're talking
or you kind of make jokes around mental
health or whatever or that sort of thing
it's about getting those barriers out
the way so that people can feel like
they can approach you using your own
vulnerability talking about stress
anxiety maybe writing a post here and
there on LinkedIn around mental health
or if you don't have that first-hand
understanding can you use resources
within your team to promote discussion
can you have time dedicated in your week
and I know a lot of businesses are doing
this now at the moment anyway where you
have a mental health check-in or if you
don't can you just be someone who says
like how are you no but honestly I'm not
worried about work at the moment how
actually I like I really want to know
how how you doing and it's about that
empathy and that compassion because if
you're someone who again is speaking
around mental health if you're writing
posts if you're getting involved with
stuff that's happening in the business
um if you are really taking that time to
be compassionate and empathetic and to
check in on on people not on work in on
people
then if I have an issue I'm gonna like
I'm gonna know that I can trust you also
there's also that point of using your
own vulnerability so if you are going
through something or if you are you're
dealing with an issue and you don't
again you don't have to go into detail
but if you can use that as as a way to
um to put your trust in your team and
say look you know I'm going through this
at the moment I'm a bit more anxious
than usual sorry if I'm off my game I've
just got some stuff I'm trying to deal
with can you have those sorts of
conversations because the moment you do
that people can take a step back take a
breather and think right you know what
Daniel's just mentioned to me about
something that last month that I'm
actually struggling with today I know I
can chat to him cool let me go and speak
to him I think that's a great way to to
increase that approachability aspect of
being being a manager the second part
comes with education
because it's great having people come to
you but there's also a detriment if that
conversation is then not handled right
so if you don't handle that conversation
of mental health right when someone
really opens up to you with something
that is is tough then the impact on the
the actual employee and the person can
could be massive so it's important that
we do educate ourselves on
what that can feel like what it can look
like the behaviors the symptoms so that
we can have and navigate those
conversations with more compassion and
more empathy but then also give a team
member the support and the guidance that
they need because if I'm a team member
again and if I open up to my manager and
conversations handled wrong or if I'm
told that
um I can't cope with the pressures of
the job or if I'm told that I'm just
being silly or lazy or whatever or
anything or any notion even and that
might not even be some language it might
be through body language if I make a
face when you talk to me about your
mental health and I'm like
making a puzzled face or if I'm like
looking sarcastic or any of those things
the ramifications on the individual that
trust Barry then is gone and they'll
never have another opportunity to open
up again because that was that was like
their point they've mustered up all this
energy to come and speak to you and the
moment they have done it's not been
handled right so it's really important
that it is an education around one how
to notice signs and symptoms around
common mental health conditions they
don't have to be older than depression
anxiety
um how that could feel for someone
listening to podcasts like this so they
can say okay well how could it impact
someone's work having discussions within
a team like that sort of thing is going
to equip you with the tools and skills
to to be someone who is approachable and
B can can handle that and can guide
someone in your team to to the support
that they actually need whether that's
internal or external and then you think
about what happens we talk about
retention issues and
um kind of within teams at the moment
and within companies at the moment
if I'm given the support that and if
that conversation is handled and my
mental health is tended to in an
environment that again can be quite
challenging
my loyalty you think about the increase
of loyalty you think about
the relationship that's developed
between that manager and that individual
that sense of connection that sense of
of
kind of gratitude for what that person
has done that's again it's just going to
go through the roof so that's why it's
really important and the effects of that
are massive yeah I love that well look I
think let's end it there I think Dan
thank you so much for being yeah
authentic
vulnerable sharing your story a bit of a
different one for all of you listening
but at the end of the day we're all hit
we're all people we're we're all human
beings and I think yeah recruitment is
difficult and I think
um if you can if this helps you speak
uh speak up or be more comfortable to
take that first step then I think we'd
be really happy if you've learned a few
things if that's developing
self-awareness or the power of personal
responsibility or about some of the
coping mechanisms and things that work
for Dan and again hopefully and that's
been really helpful for all of you but
yeah Dan love the work that you're doing
mate I think I I always respect people
who turn their hardship and really
difficult moments in their life into
um the the reason why they want to help
other people or help other people so
they don't have to go through all the
things that you went through right so
yeah no massive thank you for joining me
on the pods been an absolute pleasure
mate appreciate the time as well and
yeah thank you so much for listening to
the episode I hope you enjoyed it and
got value from the conversation if you
did enjoy it please don't forget to like
share and subscribe and we'll see you in
the next episode